joli shoot au bon soir bonsoir rodrigues
on sera tous et on va revenir sur ces
images terribles de boudhha en ukraine
avec des images qui ont fait la une des
médias depuis ce week-end où on voit des
corps sains qui jus qui jonchaient les
rues de butch assez près de kiev un
massacre de civils selon l'armée
ukrainienne et bien sûr la russie dément
moscou dénonce une mise en scène et
tente de démontrer sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans les médias qu'elle
contrôle regardez par exemple ce tweet
de l'ambassadeur adjoint de la russie
auprès de l'onu selon lui la scène dub
ou chat aurait été jouée par des acteurs
à la solde de l'ukraine et de surcroît
par de mauvais acteurs et pour étayer
son propos il s'appuie sur une une vidéo
largement reprises par des internautes
pro poutine du monde entier ainsi que
sur la télévision d'état russe comme
vous pouvez le voir une vidéo donc de
mauvaise qualité à l'image n'est pas
bonne et panet on voit un convoi et
craignant donc avancer entouré donc de
cadavres sauf que pour certains pro
russes ces personnes en fait serait bien
vivante la preuve selon eux c'est que
une de ces personnes bougerait la main
les vrais la main et vous allez le voir
dans cette vidéo ans que nous allons
lancer une petite tache blanche à leur
attention c'est très furtif regardez
vous voyez là cette petite tache blanche
qui vole au dessus du torse du soldat à
ma droite un vous voyez voilà alors ça
selon eux ce serait la preuve qu'ils le
montrent la main alors comment démontrer
un finalement que c'est vrai ou faux
parce que vraiment c'est pas clair alors
déjà il faudrait regarder la vidéo en
meilleure qualité à une vidéo kirk il
provient du ministère ukrainien de la
défense alors la voici hélas déjà quand
on la regarde au ralenti vous voyez que
la tâche est bien elle monte largement
au-dessus 1 du corps en question ça ne
ressemble pas du tout à une main mais
plutôt à une espèce de tache un sur le
pare brise on voit qu'elle se déplace ou
alors avec une goutte d'eau et pour ce
sont encore plus probant un collectif
deux internautes à inverser à passer
l'image en négatif c'est à dire que
toutes les couleurs ont été inversés et
là vous le voyez c'est probant la tanche
la tâche à gauche elle est en noir et
vous voyez quel clairement qu'elle n'est
pas sur le cadavre calé sur le pare
brise on la voit d'ailleurs monter
beaucoup plus haut donc l'information
que cette personne est vivante donc là
qu'on voit la main bouge y va c'est tout
simplement une intox alors effectivement
c'est furtif à ce qu'on peut vérifier
que c'est vrai ou faux puisque les
médias les médias pro russe la fia oui
et surtout il affirme pour une autre
vidéo inquiète un peu du même genre
alors là après le cadavre qui lèverait
donc la main les internautes et les
médias russes disent voir bouger une des
personnes censées être morte et même se
lever dès que le convoi ukrainien il a
calmé sa caméra qu'il accompagne donc
son passé donc il s'agit de cette vidéo
on va le voir sur les images diffusées
sur la tv les russes regardez
donc vous voyez là personnage à droite
la personne a droit qui regarde on a
l'impression qu'il bouge c'est
interprété par les pro russes comme donc
à quelqu'un qui se relèveraient et qui
donc ne serait pas mort sauf que là
encore il faut regarder le ralenti de la
vidéo qui se trouve ici et alors en fait
alors là des gens voient qu'il ya
quelque chose d'un peu bizarre on voit
l'image un peu se déformer en fait tu
sais pas si vous le savez mais un
rétroviseur de voitures ce n'est pas
droit c'est un peu incurvé un peu courbé
et de ce fait ça déforme un peu les
reflets que l'on voit à l'intérieur et
là encore c'est encore plus probants sur
ces captures d'écran réalisée par les
observateurs de france 24 regardez on
voit bien que la distorsion à la
déformation qui est visible sur la
personne à droite les aussi sur les
bâtiments qu'ils sont qui sont placés au
dessus envoyé le corps paraît plus fin
sur l'image de gauche quand la voiture
s'éloigne mais c'est aussi vrai pour les
les
les animaux le voilà les balancements
convoi au dessus c'est vrai aussi pour
la voiture donc là encore une fois c'est
juste une déformation du reflet la
personne n'est pas du tout en train de
se relever la seule chose qu'on voit
bouger en fait c'est la déformation donc
de ce reflet donc en fait on est bien
sûr d'eux intox merci beaucoup jugent
plutôt pour ce décryptage on retrouve
toutes vos informations sur le site
internet de france 24 points